euh donc on a une matinée extrêmement
chargée puisque nous avons deux belles
auditions et qu'il faut pas prendre de
retard sur l'audition qui va suivre donc
notre première audition avec monsieur le
Président de France industrie Alexandre
sobau que je remerci vraiment d'avoir
accepté notre invitation elle devra se
terminer à 11h puisque vous le savez à
11h on accueille le président de la
FNSEA Monsieur Arnaud Rousseau donc je
suis particulièrement heureuse de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui après des
décennies de désindustrialisation
massive votre secteur a fait l'objet
d'un intérêt renouvelé de la part des
pouvoirs publ depuis les années 2010 ici
nous ne pouvons que nous en féliciter
c'est la crise du covid qui en mettant
en lumière nos dépendance aux chaînes
d'approvisionnement international a
dévoilé les effets néfastes de décennies
de délocalisation à tout crin depuis on
parle beaucoup de
réindustrialisation de relocalisation
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'Économie
affiche l'ambition de porter la part de
l'industrie dans le PIB à 15 % c'est
actuellement moins de 10 %. pour la
première fois en 40 ans le Parlement a
examiné au printemps dernier une loi sur
l'industrie même si cette dernière
n'était pas vraiment à la hauteur de ce
que nous espérions nous ne pouvons que
nous réjouir de cette attention
renouvelée au secteur industriel
signe d'ailleurs de l'importance
particulière que nous y attachons nous
ici au Sénat notre commission va
ressusciter dans les prochaines semaines
dès le début du mois de mars son groupe
d'étude sur l'industrie qui était
présidé par Alain Châtillon et qui sera
présidé avec l'accord d'Alain par notre
collègue Martine Berté et je vous
encourage mes chers collègues pour ceux
qui ne seraient pas déjà inscrits dans
ce groupe d'étude à pouvoir le rejoindre
c'est vraiment un sujet crucial pour
l'avenir de notre pays si l'industrie
donc est revenu au cœur du débat public
il me semble pourtant que la
réindustrialisation marque déjà le pas
et ce malgré les efforts financiers
considérabl consenti dans le cadre du
plan de relance puis du plan France 2030
et en dépit des annonces triomphaliste
du gouvernement un sondage tout récent
révélé par exemple que 90 % des patrons
français installés à l'étranger
n'envisagent pas de relocaliser leur
activité en France à cela plusieurs
facteurs sur lesquels j'aimerais que
vous nous éclairiez la conjoncture
générale d'abord avec les conséquences
de l'inflation et surtout la remontée
des taux d'intérêt qui risquent de
grever la capacité d'investissement de
nos entreprises et ce alors même que
nous le savons la transition verte
nécessitera des investiss
considérable tant pour décarboner
l'industrie traditionnelle que pour
développer de nouvelles filières
d'industrie verte ensuite les prix de
l'énergie qui sont un facteur déterminé
déterminant pardon de la compétitivité
de notre industrie face à nos
concurrents américains et asiatiques
êtes-vous optimiste sur l'issue des
discussions avec EDF et avec Bery sur le
système postarène quel devrait être pour
vous le prix cible idéal pour les
consommateurs industriels et en
particulier pour ces quelques milliers
d'entreprises très
électrointensives dont l'activité dépend
complètement du coût de l'électricité
mais je sais que vous aurez aussi à cœur
de parler des industries électro
sensibles qui sont au milieu dessous
juste les les industries
électro-intensives dans l'intervalle
quels seront les effets sur le secteur
de la remonter des taxes sur
l'électricité au-delà de ces facteurs
conjoncturels quels sont pour vous les
freins structurels les plus importants
au développement d'activités
industrielles en France est-ce la
complexité des procédures d'autorisation
qui allège parfois démesurément les
délais d'implantation est-ce la
disponibilité ou le manque de foncier ou
les contraintes qui pèsent sur le
foncier est-ce le poids de la
bureaucratie et les changements
permanents de la réglementation on nous
promet d'ailleurs pour le printemps une
nouvelle loi de simplification qu'en
attendez-vous précisément j'aimerais
enfin que vous nous exposiez vos
inquiétudes concernant la mise en place
à l'horizon 2026 de la taxe carbone aux
frontières et la fin des quotas gratuits
d'émission de gaz à effet de ser car je
comprends que des difficultés majeures
se profilent pour dépend entiers de
notre industrie mais que personne n'ose
encore en prendre la pleine mesure voilà
déjà un certain nombre de questions
auquel je sais vous allez répondre avec
précision et détermination avant de vous
laisser la parole je vous précise que
cette audition est captée et elle est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et la vidéo sera ensuite
disponible en vidéo à la demande voilà
monsieur le Président je vous laisse la
parole et ensuite on ouvrira le débat
avec nos collègues qui j'en suis
convaincu vous poserons un grand nombre
de questions supplémentaires ou
complémentaires c'est à vous merci
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci d'abord pour votre invitation
évidemment le président de France
industrie a à cœur la situation et la et
les perspectives et l'avenir de
l'industrie française mais je peux pas
m'empêcher de commencer mon propos en
rappelant que sans doute plus que jamais
l'intérêt de l'industrie et l'intérêt de
notre pays ont sont alignés je crois
vraiment quand on regarde toutes les
diff qu'on a rencontré sur le commerce
extérieur sur l'échelle l'ascenseur
social en panne sur j'ai entendu hier la
SM cardisation de notre économie qui qui
est clairement pas le fait de
l'industrie puisque je le rappelle on a
de besoin d'emploi qualifié et le quand
on regarde les perspectives c'est de
plus en plus on a en moyenne des
salaires dans l'industrie qui sont 15 %
supérieur à la moyenne nationale donc on
est dans un environnement où on a besoin
de compéten on les récompense on les
reconnaît on promeut les gens on a un
ascenseur social qui
fonctionne plutôt bien compte tenu de la
de la structure de nos entreprises des
perspective et des besoins donc on est
aussi sur je le rappelle toujours hein
les 3/4 de l'emploi industriel se situe
hors métropole et donc par rapport à la
question de nos territoires oubliés des
difficultés qu'on va rencontrer
l'industrie ancre l'activité euh dans
les territoires qui en ont besoin et je
pense que une partie des difficultés
qu'on connaît ce qu'on a appelé pardon
pour la formule la diagonale du vide est
aussi le reflet de ce long et l
phénomène de désindustrialisation
pendant une quarantaine d'années que
vous avez rappelé
en introduction donc quand on regarde
tout ça on voit bien qu'il y a un
extraordinaire alignement et et ce
besoin a été encore renforcé par les
événements récents on a parlé
effectivement de la crise sanitaire et
de notre difficulté à obtenir un certain
nombre d'équipements en urgence on l'a
vu aussi avec la guerre en Ukraine notre
dépendance énergétique les perturbations
logistiques qui ont suivi et la diffé
d'approvisionnement donc l'ensemble de
notre pays et d'ailleurs de nos
industriels se sont reposé beaucoup de
questions sur les chaînes de valeur la
dépendance stratégique et on a vu à
cette occasion honnêtement pour moi
c'est la première fois là on va
peut-être trouver des traces intérieur
même l'Europe s'est posé des questions
sur des enjeux de souveraineté qui est
un débat qui n'existait pas pendant des
années l'Europe s'est vu comme le plus
grand marché du monde le plus ouvert le
plus attractif et finalement être le
plus grand marché du monde était la
façon pour l'Europe d'exercer son
influence et dans un monde qui change
comme on le voit aujourd'hui guerre
commerciale entre les États-Unis et et
la Chine voire guerre tout court dans
certaines régions du monde et y compris
assez proche de notre Europe que l'on
croyait en paix pour longtemps on voit
bien que dans cet environnement la
question de la souveraineté se pose dans
des termes radicalement différents et on
mesure aussi à cette occasion on par on
peut parler de munition que Ben ce
réarmé donc reconstruire rebâtir être
capable de produire plus c'est à la fois
indispensable et c'est encore difficile
euh la cour vous l'avez rappelé c'est
inversé hein après 40 ans de déclin
l'emploi industriel c'est ilisé voir
légèrement recommencer à croître on est
à peu près à 100000 emplois créés sur
les les 6 dernières années ce qui là
aussi est pas énorme en valeur absolue
mais quand vous regardez la tendance
précédente c'est le chiffre qu'on
détruisait les mauvaises années en un an
donc quand on fait des courbe on a une
inflexion majeure qui montre bien que
depuis que le les gouvernements ont
commencé à se préoccuper sérieusement de
la situation de l'industrie et mettre en
œuvre une politique de l'offre de
compétitivité de et de baisse d'un
certain nombre d'impôts
pense derrière tout ça aux impôts de
production il s'est passé des choses
positives
alors comme toujours dans l'industrie ça
baisse doucement et ça remonte doucement
on est sans doute l'activité économique
du temps long et donc notre grande
préoccupation dans cette période c'est
de s'assurer que ce qui a permis
d'infléchir la situation d'inverser la
tendance va s'inscrire dans la durée
parce que 10 20 30 40000 emplois par an
pour récupérer je sais pas si on
arrivera au 15 % moi je me méfie des
objectifs chiffrés mais en revanche ce
qui est important c'est que la courbe
soit bien dans la bonne direction et que
ça remonte tous les ans en terme
d'implantation industrielle en terme
d'emploi et je sais pas où on sera dans
5 10 ou 15 ans mais si la courbe reste
positive c'est sûr qu'on aura repris une
place en Europe et dans le monde qui
sera meilleure que celle qu'on a
aujourd'hui et finalement la question
qu'on se pose aujourd'hui c'est à
quelles conditions cette dynamique qui a
été enclenchée ces dernières années va
se poursuivre et là on voit un certain
nombre n d'obstacles alors il y a les
obstacles j'allais dire qui sont les
mêmes pour tout le monde la conjoncture
on est sorti d'une période de fort
rebond ça se tasse un peu aujourd'hui
nous ce qu'on observe c'est que c'est
pas la fin du monde on n'est pas enfin
quand on interroge qu'on voit la
conjoncture l'emploi les les embauches
l'activité on voit bien que ça va moins
bien qu'il y a un an et demi mais qu'on
n pas du tout dans un effondrement de
l'activité inselle mais plutôt un
atterrissage en douceur alors je me
méfie toujours des atterrissages en
douceur tant qu'on n pas touché le sol
on sait pas quel va être le point où on
arrive mais en tout cas pour l'instant
j'allais dire ça se passe sans dommage
euh grave euh après on a pour moi trois
grands défis euh le premier enfin trois
voir quatre on a le le défi de la
compétitivité c'estàdire il faut pas
penser parce que ça va mieux qu'il faut
s'arrêter on voit bien quand on ge tous
les indicateurs que nos entreprises
restent beaucoup plus taxé que la
moyenne européenne et no nos entreprises
industrielles beaucoup plus taxées que
leurs grandes homologues allemandes
espagnoles ou italiennes pour citer
juste nos grands voisins n'allons pas
chercher trop loin la concurrence qui
peut nous faire du mal euh le deuxième
grand chantier on le voit c'est au
sortir de cette crise énergétique c'est
la question de l'énergie vous l'avez
évoqué en introduction madame la
Présidente alors là aussi je me garderai
du fétichisme des chiffres même si j'ai
bien entendu la question ce que
l'industrie attend dans les différents
secteurs et notamment tous les secteurs
où l'industrie et l'électricité et
l'énergie est un sujet sensible c'est
une énergie à des prix comparables à ce
que peuvent avoir nos grands concurrents
alors quand on parle au grand
concurrents sur ce sujet c'est pas trop
l'Europe l'Union européenne on va aller
regarder l'Europe du Nord notamment la
Norvège la Suède avec les barrages et
leur capacité à à adosser à des
productions très compétitives un certain
nombre d'activité et puis surtout il
faut aller regarder en Chine et en
Amérique du Nord avec là aussi une
électricité qui aujourd'hui est
sensiblement inférieure à ce qu'on peut
trouver en France et donc la question
c'est tout l'objet des annonces du
gouvernement dans le cadre de sa
nouvelle politique électrique et de la
nouvelle stratégie de DF c'est c'est
finalement comment est-ce que la
nouvelle stratégie commerciale de DF
responsable et engagé si j'ai bien
entendu le la formulation permet bah à
tous les acteurs pour qui c'est un sujet
sensible c'est on l'a estimé autour de
8000 entreprises hyper électrointensif
électrointensif électrosensible alors à
des degrés divers pour qui si on n'est
pas capable dans les mois qui viennent
de leur offrir une énergie à prix comp
ben on verra un certain nombre
d'activités baisser vous avez je pense
tous dans vos circonscriptions et dans
vos territoires des activités de ce type
si allez leevir ils vous diront alors il
y a pas deux situations pareilles en
fonction de l'intensité concurrentielle
en fonction du coût de déplacement de la
matière il y en a certains qui vont
avoir besoin de plus près de 50 que de
70 il y en a d'autres qui vous diront je
peux y arriver quand je suis entre 60 et
70 et puis derrière quand même vous
l'évoquiez en introduction mais je pense
que c'est le moment d'en dire un mot il
y a le sujet de la compensation carbone
je rappelle que l'Europe est l'endroit
où le monde économique paye l'essentiel
des taxes carbone et donc derrière nos
consommateurs évidemment payent
l'essentiè du coût du carbone et dans
des secteurs électrosensibles
électrointensif dans lequel le prix de
l'énergie est majeur la compensation
carbone est un instrument clé de la
préservation de la compétitivité de ces
acteurs et si on n'y prend pas garde si
on met cet outil en réduction sans
s'assurer pardon que les outils qu'on va
mettre à la place fonctionnent et
aujourd'hui je pourrais revenir un peu
plus tard si vous avez des questions sur
le macf on a d'énormes doutes sur le
fait que le macf tel qu'il est construit
aujourd'hui permet de répondre à la
problématique de compétitivité de de
l'industrie concernée et en particulier
de tous nos acteurs sensibles au prix de
l'énergie donc la préservation des
quotas gratuits et de la compensation
carbone tant qu'on n pas validé et que
le système qu'on va mettre à la place
protège correctement tous les
industriels concernés et pour nous une
priorité sous peine de voir le le schéma
et la la trajectoire de
désindustrialisation reprendre je
rappelle que on est quand on regarde les
ouvertures on est sur quelques dizaines
ou quelques centaines d'ouvertures quand
on est en positif on est sur des
chiffres équivalents quand on est en
négatif là on parle de 8000 entreprises
qui pourrai être fragilisé donc les
effets sur la réindustrialisation ou la
désindustrialisation pourrait être
majeur donc le sujet de l'énergie et
tout ce qu'il y a autour est un élément
clé le troisième chantier c'est tout ce
qui va tourner autour de de ce qui est
autour de la réindustrialisation donc à
commencer par les compétences notre
capacité à être attractif là c'est notre
responsabilité industrielle de donner à
voir l'industrie de demain technologique
innovant dans lequel il fait bon
travailler avec des perspectives de
carrière des salaires attractifs c'est
c'est notre travail d'industriel et puis
il y a tout ce qui va autour
infrastructure quand on met une nouvelle
usine logement euh pour pour les
salariés qu'on voudra accueillir je
crois que le maire de dunkererque s'en
est exprimé s'est exprimé sur le sujet
avec les enjeux formidables mais quand
même un gros défi infrastructure
logement école capacité d'accueil
travail du conjoint il va se poser
autour de ces endroits où on a une vraie
réindustrialisation des questions qui
vont bien au-delà de ce que nous savons
faire tout seul et puis le dernier
chantier je ne peux pas ne pas l'évoquer
en introduction c'est la question de la
réglementation là aussi qu'on ne se
trompe
pas nous comprenons la nécessité d'une
réglementation simplement ce qu'on
observe trop souvent en Europe en
général et en France en particulier
c'est cette idée que nous devons avoir
la réglementation la plus
exigeante du monde et encore une fois ça
peut être à certains endroits un très
bon objectif stratégique sans se poser
la question de ce que font les autres et
des effets que ce niveau
extraordinairement exigeant peut avoir
sur le tissu économique et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment en permanence qu'on
se pose cette question pour apporter une
réponse qui soit ne pas renoncer à
l'ambition évidemment de protéger nos
concitoyens d'être le plus en avance
possible sur les sujets de des émission
carbone et de tout ce qui va être des
enjeux majeurs dans lequel je rappelle
l'industrie est pleinement engagée hein
l'industrie avec tout ce qui avait été
calé ces dernières années était au
rendez-vous de la snbc2 et dans le cadre
de France 2030 s mis au travail pour
faire une marche supplémentaire et
essayer d'être au rendez-vous de ce qui
sera la snbc3 et les nouveaux
objectifs venus de l'Europe avec le - 55
et tous les chiffres que vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi simplement comme je
le dis toujours être ambitieux être
exigeant oui avec une limite c'est bien
s'assurer que dans notre monde où les
choses peuvent être faites ailleurs le
faire mieux en France ou en Europe ne
voudra pas dire faire ailleurs parce que
là aussi on a une règle assez simple
qu'on a observé par partout toute
activité qu'on fait en dehors de France
émet plus de carbone que la même faite
en France même dans les conditions
équivalente cont tenu de l'électricité
décarbonée dont on dispose cont tenu de
l'ensemble de la réglementation qui est
déjà en vigueur et donc c'est vraiment
trouver ce bon équilibre entre la
nécessité de continuer à avancer sur des
enjeux majeurs protection de la planète
par rapport à échauffement climatique et
les conséquences que ça peut avoir sont
évidemment des éléments majeurs et qui
peut avoir des conséquences très lourdes
pour notre pays pour notre planète pour
nos concitoyens et donc pour l'activité
économique donc quand un industriel dit
ça il est évidemment d'abord un citoyen
mais il est aussi conscient des effets
que tout ça peut avoir sur l'activité
économique donc là-dessus n'ayez aucun
doute sur l'engagement du monde
industriel pour avancer dans cette
direction avec le travail qu'on doit
faire les échanges qu'on peut avoir en
permanence pour trouver ce bon équilibre
entre ce qu'on nous demande et ce qu'on
est capable de d'obtenir des autres et
derrière tout ça il y a la notion ce que
moi ce qu'on appelle appelle aujourd'hui
la clause miroire c'està-dire si on veut
imposer et je pense que vous aurez
quelques discussions avec mon successeur
dans cette salle donc je vais pas la
préembé mais mais là aussi c'est très
visible dans l'agriculture mais sachez
que c'est la même chose dans l'industrie
on a des sujets on est quand même les
champions pour fixer nos valeurs limites
d'exigence quand il y a des fourchettes
européennes au niveau le plus exigeant
voire même au-delà de la fourchette
Européenne j'ai pas l'impression quand
les Allemands se mettent en haut en
milieu de forchette pardon qu's a moins
souci de leur population que
nous et donc finalement le bon point
d'équilibre c'est celui qui est
accessible fonction de la technologie du
coup à partir du moment on est dans un
environnement qui paraît raisonnable et
donc comment on a ce dialogue à la fois
constructif et apaisé pour trouver le
bon équilibre et c'est aussi vrai quand
on parle de produits qui arrivve du
reste du monde si on a un niveau
d'exigence qu'on
impose à tous ceux qui produisent qui
soi industriel qui soit commerce qui
soit agriculteur qui fournisse des
services et tout ce qui tourne autour il
faut se poser la question de est-ce
qu'on est capable de s'assurer que ce
qu'on laisse rentrer sur notre
territoire qui soit européen ou français
est soumis au même niveau d'exigence et
il faut accepter quand on en est pas
capable pour de bonnes raisons parce que
le pays avec qui on veut commercer n'est
pas encore prêt parce que on veut
l'accompagner lui aussi dans une
transition bah il faut accepter que ou
pendant un certain temps ou en attendant
des réponses on soit capable de mettre
l'exigence pour le producteur français
européens au même niveau je pense que
c'est vraiment autour de ces réflexions
qu'il faut qu'on continue à travailler
non pas pour dégrader non pas pour faire
moins bien mais pour faire mieux et pour
s'assurer que comme je le dis toujours
dans l'industrie en particulier ce
secteur dans lequel quand on le fait pas
chez nous mais que le besoin demeure
c'est simplement qu'il est satisfait par
quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas j'allais
dire pardon ENF j'ai grand je travaille
beaucoup avec mes amis du logement mais
quand vous vous logez vous vous logz et
et vous pouvez pas aller vous loger de
l'autre côté de la frontière sauf
quelquefois quand vous êtes frontalier
mais globalement la mobilité sur ces
sujets quand vous fabriquez un yaourt
quand vous fabriquez un engin de levage
quand vous fabriquez une
voiture le besoin existe et tant que le
besoin existe sera satisfait par celui
qui est capable d'offrir un produit de
qualité à un prix
compétitif et donc finalement on observe
le grand enjeu de l'industrie c'est
faire mieux ne doit pas vouloir dire
faire ailleurs voilà ma présidente en
rapide d'introduction je n'ai pas traité
complètement tout ce que vous aviez dit
mais m'aviez donné 10 15 minutes et je
vaux laisser place les questions nos
collègues vont revenir sur certains
points que j'avais soulevé dans mes
propos liminires en tout cas merci déjà
pour pour pour votre vos propos et c'est
vrai qu'on voit combien aujourd'hui tant
au niveau de la souveraineté énergétique
ben on rejoint aussi la souveraineté
alimentaire et les deux auditions qu'on
va suivre ont quand même véritablement
une une cohérence ou en tout cas des
propos qui sont portés
communément pour assurer cette
souveraineté énergétique et alimentaire
alors je vais donner d'abord la parole à
la présidente du groupe d'études sur
l'industrie à Martine Berté et au
président de la délégation au
collectivités territorial ensuite
j'ouvrirai le débat et j'ai pris note de
nombreuses intervention de nos collègues
donc on va essayer quand même d'être
court dans les questions pour qu'on ait
le temps de faire passer tout le monde
et d'avoir les réponses merci Martine à
toi merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président sobau merci
également pour cette changer ces
éléments que vous nous apportez ce matin
il est vrai que la réindustrialisation
de dans notre pays est un point
important qui a été lancé par différents
dispositifs dont le plan France relance
pour lequel j'ai participé à au bilan il
y a peu de
temps alors moi j'aurais deux questions
je vais faire assez assez court
effectivement j'auraai deux questions la
première concernant justement la courbe
de
réindustrialisation quels impacts pour
vous concernant le dispositif zan de
zéro artificialisation net est-ce que
cela constitue un frein avez-vous pu
déjà analyser ces différents éléments
j'aurais une question également alors je
pense que le sujet des compétences est
en partie réglé parce que de nombreux
dispositifs ont été mis en œuvre dans le
cadre de de vos filières industrielles
mais ma question ma dernière question
posera sur la signature des contrats
long terme avec EDF par les électro
hyperélectro ou électroensi mais surtout
les hyperélectro
intensifs ces contrats de long terme
semble un petit peu être long à au
niveau de leur mise en œuvre alors que
l'on sait que il faut que cela se passe
très vite au plus tard au courant de mi
2024 puisqueensuite le dispositif de
laarène s'arrête donc que pouvez-vous
nous en dire quels sont les freins pour
vous merci merci Martine
Olivier merci madame la Présidente
président de la Délégation aux
entreprises et non collectivité
territoriale monsieur le Président Sao
la délégation aux entreprises que je
préside examine aujourd'hui un rapport
qui dénonce les obstacles rencontrés par
les entreprises françaises pour accéder
au fonciers économique vous le savez
c'est un sujet particulièrement critique
pour les PME et ETI industriel je prends
un exemple pour illustrer cette
situation les rapporteurs nos collègues
Christian Klinger et Michel mass ont
rencontré les dirigeants d'entreprise
Bridor ils ont renoncé à ouvrir un
nouveau site créateur de 500 emploi dans
son territoire historique à cause d'une
véritable Guera contentieuse notamment
sur le foncier l'allongement des délais
à tué dans l'œuf le projet les exemples
de ce type sont malheureusement très
nombreux ma question est donc la
suivante pensez-vous que la loi
industrie verte que nous avons examiné
au Sénat l'année passée est allée assez
loin de mon point de vue nous faisons
beaucoup pour les gigafactory et les
projets d'ampleur nationale mais
peut-être pas assez en terme de
simplification et d'accompagnement pour
les PME et ETI qui sont pourtant le cœur
économique de nos territoires concernant
les délais et les recours abusifs qui
sont en train de devenir une malheureuse
exception française nous devons
davantage sécuriser les projets des
entreprises sinon la réindustrialisation
que nous appelons tous de nos vux n'a
aucune chance d'aboutir êtes-vous en
accord avec cette appréciation et ques
évolution préconiseriez-vous en la
matière merci alors je vous propose de
répondre monsieur le Président à la fois
à Martine et à Olivier ensuite on ouvrir
les questions 3 par
TR pardon merci beaucoup merci pour ces
questions alors si je commence par la
courbe de réindustrialisation encore une
fois c'est très clair on a arrêté la
désindustrialisation on est sur une
remontée lente progressive donc encore
fragile
mais g la dynamique est bonne et comme
je je l'évoqué en introduction il faut
que ça se poursuive alors nous on a une
approche assez simple qui consiste à
dire que tout projet de de d'activités
industrielles nouvelles que ce soit un
étranger qui vient un Français qui
rapatrie une activité que ce soit une
PMI qui veut construire une travée
supplémentaire parce que son business se
développe qu'il a une nouvelle que une
nouvelle activité que ce soit une
start-up industrielle qui a trouvé une
solution géniale et qui est en train de
réussir et qui a besoin de construire sa
première usine ou peut-être demain de
grandir il y a pas de mauvais il y a pas
de bon et de mauvais il y a pas les
grands et les petits tout ce qui est
plus d'industrie en France cont tenu des
enjeux que j'évoquéis en introduction
doit pouvoir se faire et finalement nous
l'exercice auquel on se livre en prenant
les exemples et on essaie d'avoir des r
des dispositions vous évoquez le zan qui
sont assez récentes donc on est très
inquiet et on a commencé on a demandé à
nos à nos industriels de nous remonter à
quel moment que ce soit sur ce sujet sur
des nouvelles règles foncières les
modifications de PLU les Scott stradet
et autres joyeux dispositifs que nous
avons construit pour bien gérer
l'aménagement du territoire c'est c'est
vraiment d'identifier à chaque fois
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui
bloque et en anticipant un tout petit
peu sur la question je suis comme vous
c'estàd que quand c'est un grand projet
qui a été bien identifié ce que je pense
c'est que si la volonté de le faire
existe on viendra à bout des difficultés
dans la très grande majorité des cas en
revanche toutes ces règles qu'on vient
sédimenter notamment le zan me laisse
très perplexe quant aux petits projets
qui sont une PMI qui a besoin de
s'étendre sur l'espace qu'elle a gardé
derrière elle a gardé un hectare ou un
demi heectare pour le jour elle veut
s'étendre mais elle a évidemment gardé
en
champ je j'ai moi-même une usine dans la
région de reince et j'ai un magnifique
champ qui pourrait permettre de
l'étendre un jour je ne sais pas ce que
j'aurais le droit de faire pour
l'instant l'activité permet de
travailler dans l'environnement prévu
donc je n'ai pas posé la question mais
comment est-ce qu'on s'assure que dans
ces situations là les règles qui ont été
construites n'amènent pas un moment pour
des raisons qui par ailleurs peuvent
être compréhensibles un élut local à
refusé la demande de l'industriel parce
qu'il faut pas se faire d'illusion une
PMI si elle peut pas le faire là où elle
est elle le fera pas elle le fera pas
ailleurs elle est pas en situation de
gérer une deuxième implantation ou de
l'autre côté de la ville ou dans un
territoire voisin elle a pas
l'organisation l'infrastructure donc à
la taille où elles sont c'est là où elle
est sur l'espace qu'on peut lui libérer
juste à côté ou alors elle le fait pas
donc on a vraiment autour de ça une
vraie préoccupation alors nous on avait
fait un certain nombre de demandes
au-delà de ce que philosophiquement il
nous semble que la sobriété foncière la
gestion de la biodiversité et le fait
qu'on qu'on limite au maximum le
l'emprise sur des sols vierges est un
bon objectif stratégique il nous semble
que vouloir l'atteindre par une
interdiction par un zéro quelque chose
et sans doute pas la façon la plus
efficace d'atteindre l'objectif sans
dommage économique significatif et
d'ailleurs quand on regarde ce que font
nos voisins on s'aperçoit qu'il y a un
certain nombre de qui se sont saisis de
cette préoccupation et qui ont une
approche beaucoup plus pragmatique
autour de la sobriété quand il y a une
friche industrielle qui existe et que
l'implantation permet de répondre au
besoins bah évidemment il faut se mettre
sur la friche alors il faut traiter les
sujets de dépollution de
responsabilité je vous rappelle que là
aussi j'ai quelques exemples de
dossierers dans lequel ça s'est pas fait
parce que l'industriel qui vendait
n'était pas j'allais dire libéré de son
engagement quit à avoir fait un certain
nombre de choses que la collectivité
n'avait pas ou la volonté ou les moyens
de prendre cette responsabilité que
celui qui arrive donc on a là aussi un
certain nombre de sujets de droit euh à
traiter pour être sûr que tout ça peut
se produire que dans l'analyse d'un
projet là o on a peut-être eu une
approche un peu généreuse on se dise
quel est le la vraie surface dont vous
avez besoin qu'on se pose la question
d'organiser tout ça dans une logique de
sbrriété évidemment il faut le faire
mais quand on va vers de l'interdit et
du Zéro je pense qu'à un moment ou à
l'autre on a nous on a demandé à toutes
nos fédérations tous nos adhérents en
territoire de nous remonter toute
difficulté pour rencontrer mais j'ai
peur qu'on observe dans les années qui
viennent des situations dans lequel en
fait ça aura empêché quelque chose de se
faire alors nous on fera notre travail
de de représentation de l'industrie pour
alerter sensibiliser les collectivités
locales concernées au niveau de la
région qui a une r et qui peut porter un
certain nombre de choses au niveau de
l'État à chaque fois que c'est
nécessaire mais on sait bien quand le
système est est bien contraint et ça
renvoie
sur sur l'autre partie de la question
sur tout ce qui est recours là aussi on
est dans un état de droit j'y suis je
pense aussi attaché que vous est-ce que
pour traiter un sujet on a besoin
d'avoir C voix différentes de recours
qui sont en général assez bien géré par
les opposants pour être être séquencé et
non pas
cumulé que la justice se pose la
question s'il est saisi par quelqu'un
qui a un intérêt à agir un vrai intérêt
à agir je pense qu'on a là aussi une
réflexion à avoir non pas pour
priver le l'écosystème et le justiciable
de sa capacité à se faire entendre mais
se faire entendre parce qu'on a une
raison de le faire en une seule fois
avec des règles raisonnablement claires
et un délai euh qui permet à l'activité
économique quand la réponse est oui de
se poursuivre parce que pour revenir à
l'exemple qui a été donné sur sur midors
qui a fini par faire renoncer les gens
c'est le temps que ça a pris
c'est-à-dire que il s'est passé presque
une dizaine d'années entre le moment où
la chose a été lancée et le moment où il
a constaté que bah il était même pas
encore au bout de la perspective
juridique et que un nouveau recours
avait été
admis et donc à un moment donné il faut
bien voir que le rythme de l'activité
économique il est il est il est normal
qu'il respecte le temps de la bonne
justice mais je ne suis pas sûr que 10
ans de recours sur un projet industriel
ce soit le temps de la bonne justice
pour le dire simplement et puis pour
répondre parce que j'ai pardon vu la
cohérence des des points pas répondu sur
la parti énergie madame ber aujourd'hui
il y a pas mal de discussions qui ont
lieu effectivement entre EDF et nos
hyper
électrointensifs je crois qu'arcellor a
fait état du fait qu'il avait trouvé en
tout cas un cadre d'accord pour le
devveloppement de son activité à
dunkererc il y a un certain nombre
d'autres discussions alors nous ne
sommes pas dans le secret des
discussions puisque toutes ces
discussions sont évidemment marquées par
la confidentialité des affaires ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui c'est que ça avance
doucement certains diraient même trop
doucement par rapport à l'échéance que
vous donnez alors la fin de l'arenne
c'est fin 2025 mais pour tous ceux qui
ont des investissements à faire c'est un
horizon notamment dans ces secteurs qui
sont très intensifs en terme de de de
capital mis sur place un horizon de 18
mois et au-delà duquel on sait plus à
quel prix on aura son électricité est à
l'évidence un frein à certaines
décisions donc il faut que ça avance je
porte ce message aussi souvent que
possible auprès du patron de def dont je
dont je je reconnais la la volonté
d'avancé les engagements qu'il a pris
maintenant l'exécution de tout ça est un
exercice compliqué aujourd'hui j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur le sujet il
y a quelques temps le tissu industriel
dépendant du prix de l'électricité est
dans un état d'inquiétude contestable
parce que les sujets sont complexes
parce que les outils qui sont proposés
sont pas tous simples à mettre en œuvre
ou ne sont pas encore tous parfaitement
adapté au besoins la vérité c'est qu'on
change de monde hein des environnement
qui était très réglementé avec une
perspective que tout ça s'arrête et ce
qui fera la compétitivité de l'industrie
française c'est ça a été dit he c'est la
nouvelle politique commerciale de DF bah
il faut que il faut que ça se traduise
et aujourd'hui on est au début
donc VO il faut que il faut qu'on batte
la mesure il faut que ça continue à
avancer j'allais dire ce qui me rassure
le plus dans cet exercice c'est que le
gouvernement s'est clairement englagé
une clause de rendez-vous à l'été enfin
avant l'été dans lequel on fera un bilan
de ce qui s'est passé et il a bien mis
la compétitivité de notre industrie
comme un des éléments clés d'évaluation
de la pertinence de ces choix et de la
capacité d'avancer donc on va continuer
à travailler dur pour être capable de
faire un bilan à la date et j'espère que
il restera si ça s'avère nécessaire une
fenêtre législative pour procéder à des
amendements si il s'avèrait nécessaire
mais clairement le texte de loi tel
qu'on a vu un projet sortir c'est pas ce
texte qui traite de la compétitivité de
l'industrie il traite de la protection
macro du système il traite d'un certain
nombre de choses mais on l'a dit depuis
le début ce qui fera la compétitivité
c'est le prix que nos opérateurs a
commencé par le premier pour faire à
l'industrie pour qu' le sujet est
sensible et on est au début de ces
discussions et c'est vrai qu'elles
avancent on va le dire comme ça
doucement merci alors on va prendre les
questions de Philippe grosvallet de
Christian Redon sarazi et d'Amel
gaaker assez rapidement s'il vous plaît
oh je n'interviens pas souvent madame la
Présidente non je voudrais moi
interroger France industrie sur une
évolution très nouvelle euh du
développement industriel j'habite sur un
l'espre de la Loire donc un espace
extrêmement sensible sur le plan
environnemental mais aussi sur le plan
social où se développent des industries
diverses des industries carbonées une
raffinerie une centrale au charbon
encore mais aussi on construit des
avions des paquebau je regarde mes amis
écologistes en disant cela mais aussi le
premier territoire à accueillir un parc
éolien offshore en France si je vous
interroge c'est
que nous sommes finalement micro
laboratoire du développement industriel
soit pour des implantations nouvelles
soit pour développer nos propres
industries et je considère que le monde
industriel est encore trop peu à
l'écoute de cette double sensibilité
d'abord celle de notre environnement
notamment chez nous la question de l'eau
de l'air du
sol et puis également la sensibilité
citoyenne ou si ces préoccupations ne
sont pas prises en compte il n'y aura
pas de développement industriel or il y
a encore des entreprises voyouses comme
par exemple Yara qui préfère sur cette
estire en fabriquant des produits
chimiques qui d'ailleurs devrait
concourir à à à à la souveraineté
agricole de notre pays préfère payer des
amendes très lourdes plutôt que euh de
se conformer au règlement euh que euh
lui impose la France donc euh je pense
que cette culture nouvelle pour le monde
industriel n'est pas suffisamment prise
en compte alors que alors que euh des
potentiels importants se font et c'est
l'objet de ma question s'agissant des
énergies renouvelable euh comment euh
France industrie perçoit l'évolution de
la part industrielle consacré aux
énergies renouvelables dans les années
futures et comment nous comparons-nous
d'ailleurs aux autres pays européens
quand on sait que par exemple les
Chantiers de l'Atlantique qui fabrique
des bateaux ont pris une commande
récemment aux États-Unis pour une
sousstation c'estàd un seul objet d'un
parconen aushore qui dont le chiffre
d'affaires sera une fois et demi
supérieur au prix d'un des plus gros
pquebot du monde donc on voit bien les
enjeux y compris pour la balance
commerciale de la France à s'engager
dans les énergies renouvelables on a
beaucoup parlé encore hier euh de
langage sur le nucléaire moi je crois
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à
l'engagement industriel sur notamment
les énergies renouvelables donc comment
France industrie perçoit ses évolutions
environnementales sociales et
économiquees merci Philippe Christian
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président aujourd'hui le l'industrie
c'est plus de de directement plus de 3
millions de d'emplois mais plusieurs
décennies de désindustrialisation ont
laissé les traces durbles en particulier
au niveau des compétences he fin 2022 65
% des entreprises du secteur
manufacturier déclaré avoir des
difficultés de recrutement et ce
pourcentage n'a jamais été aussi élevé
depuis depuis 2000 cette pénurie
concerne tous les niveaux et malgré le
nombre d'offres on observe toujours un
déficit d'orientation vers ces filières
en dépit notamment de de belles
perspectives de carrière offerte par
exemple par les écoles d'ingénieurs et
les parcours de formation aujourd'hui
qui existent l'apprentissage a fortement
progressé mais je pense qu'on atteint on
atteint un plafond donc ma question
c'est pensez-vous que que les
recrutements qui à venir seront en
volume et en qualité à la hauteur des
besoins que la réindustrialisation que
nous souhaitons tous arrivera quand
quand elle arrivera et sinon quelle
quelle piste envisagez-vous au niveau
national ou sur un périmètre plus élargi
pour y remédier merci Amel gaker merci
madame la Présidente je vais finalement
commencer par ma deuxème question pour
retirer le fil de la question précédente
de mon collègue revenir donc sur l'enjeu
des compétences donc j'ai bien entendu
et c'est vrai que nous nous l'évoquons
régulièrement notamment avec Sophie
primain on a eu l'occasion de le faire
dans un rapport il il y a quelques mois
donc j'ai bien entendu la prise de
conscience de cet impératif de disposer
de la mobilité moi mon ma question en
tout cas mon point d'attention c'est
surtout le développement de réponses
adapté de réponses des territoires sur
cet enjeu de main d'œuvre dont on a
besoin et donc deux points d'attention
les tensions en fait aujourd'hui de main
d'œuvre se retrouve dans les territoires
aussi parce que on retrouve un taux ce
qu'on appelle un taux d'évaporation des
jeunes formés au métiers industriel fort
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
clairement ces jeunes qui aujourd'hui
sont formés au métiers industriel mais
qui n'occupe pas ces métiers les métiers
pour lesquels ils sont formés pour deux
raisons soit parce que ils sont orientés
vers des filières par défaut ils se
rendent compte que ça ne les intéresse
pas puis le deuxième sujet c'est celui
de la mobilité c'est-à-dire être formé
sur des métiers sur lesquels il n'y a
pas de besoin sur leur bassin les écoles
de production je vous dis ça pourquoi
parce qu'il y a des réponses aujourd'hui
sur lesquel de mon point de vue il faut
accélérer les écoles de production qui
clairement sont des solutions qui
répondent à des besoins exprimés par des
consortiums d'entreprise donc
aujourd'hui votre point de vue je pense
le connaître moi ce qui m'intéresse
surtout c'est est-ce que ces réponses
sont vraiment développées
particulièrement spécifiquement et puis
deuxième petite chose sur cette
questionl c'est la réponse globale euh
on a eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
régulièrement avec euh de avec la
présidente bien sûr qu'il y a la réponse
de compéten mais les réponses globales
qu'il faut apporter vous l'avez dit
logement service mobilité est-ce que
aujourd'hui dans la al bien sûr dans mon
territoire je suissu des haut defance
euh encore avec la l'annonce là euh
d'une nouvelle entreprise de Tiamat à à
mien euh on se rend compte que le le le
sujet va encore davantage prendre de
place mais on a de vraies réponses mais
globales àortter juste une petite
question pardon sur un sujet qu'on n pas
évoqué c'est juste sur le plan
relocalisation sur lequel la Cour des
comptes a émis un avis plutôt mitigé fin
d'année 2023 en disant que ce plan
aujourd'hui n'était pas forcément à la
hauteur et que nous n'avions pas assez
avancé sur notre souveraineté
industrielle je m'arrête là merci merci
je propose de répondre
à merci beaucoup un petit peu de travail
effectivement pour répondre à tout ça
alors pour pour commencer par la
première question je veux le redire
aujourd'hui je pense que encore une fois
c traiter les cas individuels je n'ai
pas vocation à traiter les cas
individuels mais en tout cas pour ce que
l'on observe entre l'engagement des
filières l'ensemble des contrats de
transition écologique les 50 sites à
plus haut potentiel de décarbonation qui
qui sont engagés je pense que
l'industrie est engagée sans état d'âme
sur une vraie trajectoire de
décarbonation avec les deux questions
que j'aiévoqué en introduction qui sont
comment est-ce qu'on assure que cette
trajectoire est soutenable
financièrement et raisonnablement
compétitive une fois que ça fonctionne
et on rebou sur le prix de l'électricité
puisque dans la majorité des cas la
trajectoire de décarbonation c'est de
remplacer une source d'énergie qui était
aujourd'hui fossile que ce soit du
charbon du pétrole du gaz par de
l'électricité décarbonée ou mais ce qui
revient au même par de l'hydrogène donc
tous ces procédés nécessite de
l'électricité décarboné en quantité
suffisante et et il y a aucun doute
quand vous prenez la des engagements il
y a vraiment aujourd'hui je pense que
plus personne ne peut contester le
travail qui est fait la contribution
dans le passé à l'industrie à de
l'industrie à la décarbonation de notre
économie et le fait que vous prenez les
grands secteurs l'industrie est le seul
qui aujourd'hui est capable de démontrer
qu'elle sait être au rendez-vous des
obligations qui lui avaient été fixées
par la loi et qui travaille déjà à tenir
les engagements supplémentaires qui
pourrait lui être demandé dans les
années à venir un tout petit mot sur les
énergies renouvelables moi je suis je
suis technologiquement agnostique
c'est-à-dire que ce qui compte c'est que
l'énergie soit décarbonée si on veut
sauver la planète il faut émettre moins
de carbone et donc chaque pays en
fonction de ses choix stratégiques de
son histoire des technologies qu'elle
maîtrise apporte la réponse qu'il
souhaite et la seule chose qui compte
c'est la part de carbone dans la
production d'électricité nationale alors
je suis le premier àêre très perplexe
que l'Europe décidé que ça devait être
une part de renouvelable je ve dire
imposer du renouvelable dans des à des
pays qui ont si encore une fois qui ont
la capacité de produire d'électricité
décarbonée sans 20 ou 25 ou 30 ou 40 %
de renouvelable je vois pas bien ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut pas le faire si
c'est une solution efficace compétitive
performante mais autour de ça il faut
rester sur une ligne simple qui est
est-ce que notre électricité est
décarbonée aujourd'hui l'électricité
française et la plus décarbonée d'Europe
je rappelle que tous les jours nos amis
allemands qu'on cite en modèle
produisent une électricité qui est
suivant les jours et l'intensité de
production entre 5 à 10 fois plus
carboné que la
nôtre donc la la question qui se pose
est juste celle-là et autour de ça bah
voilà chaque pays et c'est le choix de
la représentation nationale après débats
et écoute des acteurs fait des choix de
stratégie énergétique mais il faut pas
s'enfermer dans une solution une autre
un pays qui je pense à la Norvège ou à
la Suède qui a énormément de de capacité
à faire de
l'hydraulique qui est une industrie une
électricité totalement décarboné très
largement
pilotable peut avoir des besoins
moindres de d'apporter d'autres
solutions tout en tenant ses objectif
d'une
énergie décarboné sur l'emploi sur lesés
de recrutement sur l'orientation et
cetera pardon moi je crois profondément
que c'est la transparence qui permettra
d'avancer on défend depuis très
longtemps cette idée que tout cursus de
formation qui soit initial que ce soit
de l'apprentissage des écoles
d'ingénieurs des écoles de production
que ce soit des lycées professionnels ou
autres doit pouvoir dire aux gens qui
rentrent dans un cursus ça doit être
vrai pour les chômeurs ça doit être pour
les gens qui veulent changer de travail
dans les transitions professionnelles ou
des évolutions de carrière ça doit
évidemment être vrai aussi quand on va
accompagner par qu'on a des grands en
jeu sur l'emploi des seniors quand on va
accompagner toutes ces populations il
faut absolument quand les gens rentrent
dans un cursus de formation ils aient
une absolue transparence sur trois
choses est-ce qu les chance qu'ils ont
d'aller au bout c'est-à-dire quel est le
taux de succès obtenenstion du diplôme
moyen de tous les gens qui sont rentrés
deuxièmement quel est le taux
d'insertion dans l'emploi avec des
critères simples c'est alors aujourd'hui
la question se pose moins avec la
quantité de CDI mais c'est un CDD de
plus de 6 mois ou un CDI moins de 6 mois
après la sortie du cursus et puis la
trème chose c'est le niveau de revenu ou
le niveau de salaire qu'on peut attendre
en sortie de formation et croyez-moi si
on est capable avec l'engagement de tous
pour chaque formation qui est mis qui
est mis sur le marché de répondre à
cette question je pense qu'on va assez
naturellement parce que les gens sont
qui ce soit les parents les jeunes ou
les gens qui à se reconvertir faire une
formation pour aller à un endroit où le
taux d'insertion dans l'emploi plus
faible que là d'où on vient et donc le
salaire est moins bon je pense que ça va
en décourager certains et dans dans mes
activités patronal j'ai eu l'occasion de
siéger il y a quelques années au conseil
de Pôle emploi et j'ai bien vu que B
aujourd'hui on répondait pas à ça qu'il
y avait des gens qui faisaient des choix
don je pense que quand ils seront au
bout de leur cursus ils le regretteront
parce qu'ils vont se mettre à un endroit
du marché du travail qui est beaucoup
moins bon que celui où ils étaient avant
et je pense que compte tenu tout ce que
l'industrie a offrir dans ce domaine en
terme de parcours professionnel de
niveau de salaire d'intérêt de sens
parce que je vous rappelle que
l'industrie étant largement engagée dans
la décarbonation ce que je dis à tout le
monde c'est que si vous êtes jeune
aujourd'hui vous voulez contribuer à
sauver la planète le meilleur endroit où
vous pouvez aller c'est l'industrie
française on a besoin de jeunes
ingénieurs on a besoin de cadres on a
besoin de compétences et je voudrais pas
qu'on échoue sur tous nos grands projets
qui soi autour de la décarbonation de la
réindustrialisation par manque de de
ressources humaines de de gens qui ont
envie et qui viennent travailler chez
nous et je suis convaincu que la
transparence sur tout ça est
indispensable après sur l'apprentissage
il y a eu un vrai développement on a
écouté les les inquiétudes et les les
blocages du monde économique ça ça s'est
traduit par une vraie augmentation je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure moi je n'ai pas
le féticisme du chiffre ce qui est
important c'est que tous ceux qui voient
cette voix comme une bonne façon de
trouver un métier qui les intéresse et
d'accéder au marché du travail puisse le
faire est-ce que c'est 700000 800000 un
million ou plus je n'en ai pas la
moindre idée l'université est aussi un
formidable endroit on a parlé des écoles
de production on a parlé des lycées pro
avec des réformes en cours tout ce qui
permet de donner des compétences à tous
ceux qui en ont besoin pour venir
travailler chez nous doit être encouragé
et soutenu et les quelques critères que
j'évoqué me
semblent les plus pertinent pour y
arriver et après on a je l'ai évoqué en
introduction on a nous une vraie
responsabilité en tant qu'industriel on
a fait des campagnes avec l'opcodosi
dans quelques fédérations pour montrer
l'intérêt et la contribution du monde
industriel aux enjeux du pays pour
donner envie aux gens de de venir
travailler chez nous il y a une grande
campagne de Loco il y a la fabrique de
l'avenir alors on en fait sûrement pas
assez on a aussi engagé des travaux avec
en territoire avec avec les régions pour
l'orientation pour rentrer dans les
lycées dans les collèges pour pour
donner à voir la réalité de l'industrie
vous savez quand vous regardez la vie
d'un enfant
aujourd'hui sauf s'il a des parents l'un
de ces deux parents qui travaillent dans
l'industrie le monde industriel est le
seul secteur avec lequel il a
naturellement aucune
interaction vous avez des interactions
avec le monde du commerce le monde des
services le monde du bâtiment parce que
c'est dans votre vie quotidienne vous
allez aller faire des courses
accompagner vos parents vous allez voir
un artisan venir faire des travaux chez
vous vous allez découvrir ce monde
l'industrie c'est un endroit fermé dans
lequel si vous rentrez pas vous savez
pas ce qui se passe dedans donc on
défend une idée simple c'est que avant
la fin avant la fin de la 7e comme les
enfants adorent faire une visite au
musée ben il faudrait rajouter une
visite à l'usine ils adorent et en plus
quand ils y vont le le pire c'est quand
ils y vont ils sont très contents ils
voient des choses auxquelles ils
s'attendaient pas du tout très loin des
images d'Épinal alors est-ce qu'on est
assez mobilisé je ne sais pas en tout
cas ça fait partie des messages qu'on
pose qu'on travaille avec l'Éducation
nationale on travaille avec les
territoires et pardon dernier point sur
la réponse globale et l'ancrage des
territoires on ne fera rien sans le
soutien et l'accompagnement du
territoire d'accueil à la fois pour
l'acceptabilité on l'a vu quand même à
certains endroits c'est compliqué la
pédagogie on fera rien parce que quand
il y a des enjeux lourds les
infrastructures les écoles le logement
on peut contribuer mais on peut pas tout
faire donc se mettre dans une démarche
prévisionnelle là-dessus et travailler
ensemble ce sont vraiment des éléments
importants et puis pardon pour ma
réponse mais je n'ai pas relu avec
attention le rapport de la Cour des
comptes donc je me garderai de faire une
une réponse détaillée sur une analyse
que je n'ai pas faite moi ce que je veux
redire c'est que ce qui est important
c'est pas est-ce qu'on relocalise est-ce
qu'on relocalise pas c'est est-ce que
l'industrie se développe et il y a pas
une bonne réindustrialisation toute
personne qui a envie de faire un peu
plus d'industrie en France et la
bienvenue est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui
revient est-ce que c'est à travers CHUS
France qu'on a donné envie à un grand
groupe international de venir
s'implanter chez nous c'est très bien
est-ce que c'est la PMI qui est
convaincu qu'elle peut s'agrandir là où
elle est qui a un beau projet et qui le
met et donc je resterai là pour ma
réponse sans doute suffisante avec merci
je demande vraiment à nos collègues de
raccourcir leurs questions on va passer
aux questions de Sylvi Noë Yve blunven
et Serge merilou Sylvian merci madame la
présidente monsieur le Président je
souhaite vous interroger sur le sujet de
la
macf qui conduira à renchérir le prix de
l'acier et de l'aluminium pour les
industriels européens alors que leurs
concurrents hors d'Europe qui ne
subiront pas ce surcout pourront y
importer leurs produits transformés sans
taxe par ailleurs ce mécanisme chérit
grandement le surcût administratif pour
les TPE et les PME industriell
sous-traitante aval à l'heure où il est
au contraire urgent de simplifier et
d'alléger sans parler des risques
d'infraction douanièr et même des
surcûts par l'application de valeurs
pénalisantes dans les cas où les
déclarations ne seraient pas fournies ou
erronées la période transitoire actuelle
doit nous permettre de tout faire pour
que le champ d'application de cette taxe
soit élargi à d'autres produits
transformés aux composants mécanisme et
au bien d'équipement comportant une
forte proportion d'acier sous sous peine
d'une distorsion de concurrence majeure
qu'en est-il de l'avancée des
discussions avec la Commission
européenne qui doit faire des
propositions législatives en ce en ce
sens pardon et quelles sont les pistes
concrètes pour trouver un autre système
permettant de neutraliser l'effet du
prix carbone sur la compétitivité
relative de la filière avale avec le
reste du monde je vous remercie
Yve merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le le président de de France industrie
je vais pas revenir sur les propos
d'Olivier notre président de délégation
des entreprises mais c'est clair que il
faut faire quelque chose sur la
problématique des procédures qui sont
enclenchées systématiquement chaque fois
que un industriel veut ouvrir une usine
moi je reviendrai sur trois petits
points rapidement le premier c'est face
à une qui se rarifie qui est le foncier
on risque d'avoir la concurrence sur les
implantations et l'industrie parfois et
là pour le coup la variable d'ajustement
on préfère faire du tertiaire on préfère
faire du col blanc et malheureusement
les territoires ont tendance à faire des
choix qui ne sont pas favorables à
l'industrie il faut absolument qu'on
défende l'industrie sur les territoires
parce qu'un territoire sans emploi
industriel c'est un territoire qui va
passer à côté de l'employabilité de ses
ses habitants et c'est pour pour ça que
la labalisation territoire d'industrie
est importante mais je pense que on nen
fait pas assez pour pouvoir bien
rééquilibrer les choses le deuxième
élément c'est comment vous réagissez
face à des propositions qui commencent à
vous venir aujourd'hui de certains
territoires notamment je pense au bail
amphiéotique parce que le foncier on va
pas le le renouveler il faut qu'on
l'utilise intelligemment et là-dessus
j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis
d'industriel ou de représentants des
industriels et la troisième chose créer
des emplois c'est important sur les
territoires mais il faut aussi des
logements qui vont avec et il faut qu'on
ait absolument des politiques liées
entre la réindustrialisation du pays et
des politiques de logement on connaît
l'importance de la participation des
entreprises au travers de la PEC pour la
construction des logements mais je pense
que il faut faut aller bien au-delà et
puis il faut sans doute revenir sur une
régionalisation de l'usage de ces fonds
parce que tout ramener à Paris c'est
sympathique mais euh sans avoir la
garantie qu'on a des retours sur le
territoire qui investit merci Serge
merilou madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président deux questions rapides une
concernant le foncier ça a largement été
évoqué mais l'accès au foncier c'est un
enjeu majeur et je voulez vous
questionner sur la mise en place du
dispositif site clé en main qui est
prévu dans la 2uxe phase du programme
territoire d'industrie ces sites clé en
main ont pour ambition de faciliter
l'accès au fonciers dans dans des
territoires concernés par ce programme
et selon vous cette mesure sera-t-elle
suffisante pour relancer
l'industrialisation dans ces secteurs et
quels seront les les critères à
respecter pour ces sites et puis une
deuxème question sur sur l'emploi qui a
déjà été évoqué mais pas par le biais
pour lequel je voulais l'évoquer le
dernier tableau de bord produit par
France industrie en descemb présent des
conclusions inquiétantes en matière
d'activité industrielle de la France le
rapport évoque la prudence des
entreprise en matière d'investissement
et d'emploi et encore une fois dans le
cadre du programme territoire
d'industrie le dispositif
volontariat territorial en entreprise va
être mise en place on peut saluer cette
mesure qui permettrait d'attirer des
jeunes talent dans les PME et les ETI
industrielles toutefois dans ce contexte
de ralentissement de l'investissement ne
sera-t-il pas compliqué de mettre cette
mesure en œuvre et finalement est-ce que
les entreprises sont en cap d'accueillir
ces jeunes merci voilà monsieur le
Président assez concis de votre côté
aussi si je peux me
permettre si je mets pas le micro ça va
pas être bien sur le macf je je n'ai pas
grandchose à ajouter à ce que vous avez
dit on répète depuis le début et là
aussi soyons clair en terme de principe
mettre un coup au carbone et faire
monter progressivement ce coup pour
inciter par les économie par le le
fonctionnement naturel de l'économie
est-ce que les activités qui peuvent le
plus facilement se transformer en
consomant moins de carbone se transforme
est une bonne
idée la difficulté c'est que pour
qu'elle fonctionne dans un monde ouvert
il faut que les grandes régions du monde
acceptent de mettre en œuvre la taxe
donc il faut que la Chine et les
États-Unis mettre en œuvre une taxe de
ce type parce que quand on la prend à la
source quand on la prend sur la
production des matières premières et que
tout le monde paye qu'elle soit 70 80
peut-être demain 90 100 ou 120 on ne on
ne change absolument pas les règles de
compétitivité puisque tout le monde paye
le même cout on le prend à l'origine là
où on sait bien le mesurer finalement le
système fonctionne la grande difficulté
qu'on a pour mettre en œuvre ce
dispositif c'est que et les Chinois et
les Américains nous ont très clairement
dit qu'il ne le ferait pas et l'IRA aux
États-Unis et la démonstration que les
États-Unis ont fait le choix de
subventionner le décarboné et de ne pas
taxer le carbone alors j'ai pas à moi de
dire si ce choix est bon ou mauvais mais
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité et ce
qu'on constate depuis qu'on a on est
rentré dans ce schéma c'est qu'en
revanche vouloir attraper à l'entrée
dans l'Europe le contenu carbone de
produit est un exercice assez compliqué
alors il est raisonnable quand on est
sur un produit de base un tube d'acier
c'est à peu à peu près c'est à peu près
il est construit dans les mêmes
conditions il est fabriqué dans les
mêmes conditions on sait en définir
assez bien le contenu quand on arrive à
une porte de voiture c'est plus
compliqué quand le produit est fini
c'est un exercice compliqué c'est le
gros avantage de la taxe sur la valeur
ajoutée c'est que ce que vous taxer
c'est la valeur donc c'est le prix qui
est en bas de la facture quand vous
rentrez un produit son contenu carbone
il est assez difficile de à l'entrée de
le déterminer et donc il faut la bonne
volonté de celui qui l'a fabriqué mais
quand il veut importer chez vous qui
veut pas mettre en en place de taxe
carbone l'exercice est
extraordinairement compliqué donc on a
dit depuis le début on a fait état de
nos difficultés vous l'avez évoqué sur
des produit semifi ou fini avec le
risque que cette taxe soit finalement
une incitation à faire en dehors
d'Europe pour qu'on importe sans taxe un
produit semifini ou fini là où en
important le produit de base et en le
transformant en Europe on aurait un un
coût plus élevé donc on a posé toutes
ces questions au gouvernement français
on l'a posé à la Commission européenne
on est passé de la réponse en gros on va
trouver des enfin c'est pas un vrai
problème et ça va marcher à vous avez
posé des bonnes questions on va trouver
les réponse ça fait maintenant un peu
plus de 3 ans que je suis président de
France industrie ça fait donc un peu
plus de 3 ans que j'ai posé cette
question et à Paris et à Bruxelles et
que j'attends une réponse satisfaisante
et notre demande là-dessus elle est très
claire c'est que tant qu'on n' pas des
réponses qui permettent de rassurer sur
la compétitivité de l'industrie
française et européenne sur ces sujets
il ne faut pas réduire les quotas
gratuits parce que c'est une condition
de la survie de nombreux secteurs
industriels et comme là aussi je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure le besoin ne
disparaîtra pas si ces secteurs
disparaissent on va simplement importer
des choses qu'on ne fait plus en France
ou en Europe dans des conditions encore
moins respectueuses de l'environnement
que les activités qu'on aura qu'on aura
arrêté sur les procédures ou là aussi à
un moment il faut se poser une question
simple c'est combien de procédures en
parallèle ou en supplément on peut
lancer qui a un intérêt à agir et à quel
moment est-ce que mais ça c'est vraiment
un choix de la représentation nationale
moi je constate les faiblesses de la
construction qu'on a fait du droit de
recours dans tous les sens de la non
limitation de l'intérêt à agir quand on
voit tout ce qu'on demande à une
organisation comme France industrie ou à
tous ses adhérents en terme de
transparence financière de
représentativité et cetera on peut se
poser la question de savoir si pourrait
pas se poser la question dans
l'environnement associatif ONG et tous
ces gens qui interviennent avec parfois
des agendas qui me semble pas tout à
fait aligné avec l'intérêt de notre pays
quels sont leurs financement leur moteur
et cetera donc mais c'est une décision
qui me dépasse
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui permet de de
prendre une décision moi je peux
simplement partager le fait que il y a
un certain nombre de dossiers dans
lequel le nombre de recours qui se sont
enchaîner à fragiliser notre capacité à
faire mais le fait de savoir quelle est
la bonne réponse est une réponse qui
vous appartient entièrement parce que je
suis le
premier défenseur de l'idée selon
laquelle on doit être challengé donc le
fait qu'il ait des contrepouvoir qu'il
ait des gens qui aient des avis
différents qu'ils ai plus que vois au
chapitre et qu'on c'est l'industriel est
d'autant meilleur qu'il est challengé
après challenger juridiquement pendant
10 ans est-ce que on n'est pas un point
d' qui n'est pas tout à fait optimal et
donc voilà quel type de règle on peut
s'imposer tout en respectant l'État de
droit la liberté de chacun
agir je suis désolé mais là cette
question me me dépasse elle doit elle
relève des choix de la représentation
nationale et je me garderais bien de
d'aller au-delà bail
hitthéotique je pense que c'est pas dans
notre culture ça inquiète un peu donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la difficulté dans
la durée on est plus sur les questions
de de responsabilité de pollution dans
le temps de dépollution de coût de la
dépollution et que finalement quand des
des terres ou des territoires genre
friche industriel sont gelés c'est
beaucoup plus pour des questions de
gestion de la responsabilité dans la
durée qu'autre chose et donc je pense
que si on est capable de trouver des
réponses à cette question on est capable
d'assurer la transmission et la gestion
sobre de la
réindustrialisation enfin sur tout ce
qui est site clé en
main le gros avantage d'un site clé en
main c'est qu'il est entre guillemets
prêt enfin en tout cas pour beaucoup de
critères après en fonction de l'activité
qui s'implante il peut y avoir des
choses supplémentaires à faire mais on
peut pas demander au site clé en main de
savoir ce qui va venir s'implanter après
il a un défaut c'est qu'il est à un
endroit et donc est-ce que cet endroit
est adapté à l'activité qui veut venir
s'implanter et là aussi comme je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure la question c'est
il faut proposer il faut essayer de se
mettre là où on peut mais je ne peux pas
vous promettre que toutes les activités
qui voudront venir se mettre chez nous
sont capables de sont voileintérêt et la
pertinence comme choix d'être à un
endroit où il existait déjà une surface
prête à les accueillir c'est il faut il
faut pousser dans ce sens-là ça
participe de la sobriété et en tout cas
nous c'est les messages qu'on passe mais
à un moment donné c'est celui qui
investit celui qui prend la décision qui
doit être convaincu que l'endroit qu'on
lui propose répond à sa problématique et
c'est évidemment l'endroit o il est
c'est les infrastructures c'est
l'écosystème autour c'est le logement en
fonction de l'activité il faut rester un
peu humble et pragmatique sur est-ce que
c'est bien adapté en tout cas nous on
milite dans ce domaine pour le respect
d'une règle de sobriété et que à chaque
fois qu'on peut se mettre à un endroit
où il y a déjà eu quelque chose où on
n'empiète pas sur les terres naturelles
après je rappelle quand même que à
l'échelle de la France les zones
artificialisées pour l'industrie sont
totalement symboliques puisqu'on est à
moins de 1 %
de la totale de la surface de notre beau
pays alors on va prendre les questions
de Yannick jade Rémy Cardon et Bernard
bu s'il vous plaît concise y j merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président vous avez évoqué parfois
provoquer mais on a pas le temps du
débat
donc non voyez je le faisen bon en
sortant avec plaisir monsieur le S mais
avec grand plaisir mais nous avons une
autre audition juste après donc je suis
pas sûr qu'on a beaucoup temps à la
pause euh effectivement notre pays a
beaucoup délocalisé beaucoup sur des
questions de coûts sociaux et
aujourd'hui il réindustrialise et tant
mieux autour de la question climatique
de la décarbonation et c'est
incontestablement le résultat de la
conviction des chefs d'entreprise de
leurs équipes des salariés mais aussi de
la loi de la règle et je vais dire le
gros mot de la norme euh euh aujourd'hui
euh quand on est à Bruxelles et quand on
est en France il y a pas les industriels
il y a pas les entreprises on a beaucoup
parlé du mécanisme d'ajustement carbone
s'il y avait une position des
entreprises ce serait simple s'il y a
pas les produits finis ou semi-finis
c'est aussi le résultat des pressions
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises qu'
ont pas voulu que ce soit intégré dans
le mécanisme d'ajustement carbone et ma
question est différente les États-Unis
incontestablement et la Chine
investissent massivement dans une
nouvelle industrie des car BNA autour de
la transition écologique ils le font
avec des normes mais surtout ils le font
avec de l'investissement et des marchés
publics donc j'ai là aussi j'aimerais
connaître votre position en tant que
France industrie dans cette discussion
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ce que
l'Europe fasse un emprunt commun pour
faire une vraie politique industrielle
de soutien aux entreprises comme les
États-Unis 370 milliards et sur les
marchés publics le mot européen c'est
réciprocité mais ça veut rien dire parce
que la réciprocité ça veut pouvoir dire
être aussi ouvert que l'Europe c'est ce
que défendent une bonne partie des
industriels et des entreprises au niveau
européen ou aussi fermé que les autres
voyez bien que c'est pas le même sujet
est-ce que vous êtes pour un by European
Act don tout le monde parle ou comme la
plupart des des organisations
industrielles et économiques au niveau
européen ils ne veulent pas de de by
European Act
merci merci Madame la
présidenteen un peu les les trois
objectifs
de de de ce qui a été produit dans le
texte industrie verte on l' ça a été dit
faciliter la construction d'usine
financer l'innovation industrielle et
puis essayer de verdir on va dire
l'industrie en transformant les procédés
ces trois objectifs bon il y a encore
une certaine timidité je dirais dans les
les budgets alloués sur France 2030
donacte par rapport si on en tout cas on
se compare à à ce qui est fait aux
États-Unis ou autres moi dans ce que
j'ai entendu vous avez dit il y a trois
trois enjeux compétitivité énergie et
compétence le cas de de Tiamat à Amien
puisque en tant que sénateur de la Somme
j'ai suivi le dossier de de près c'est
en fait on a commencé par les
compétences on a misé dans la recherche
et en l'occurrence l'UPJV l'université
Picardie juleverne qui a mis des des
moyens conséquents en ayant bien sûr
Jean-Marie Tarascon professeur qui a lui
mis beaucoup de énergie là-dedans mais
c'est par la compétence qu'on arrive à
relancer l'industrie et là en
l'occurrence là je trouve que la
question bah oui j'y viens en
l'occurrence je trouve que dans ce qui a
été produit dans les derniers textes et
dans la stratégie française je ne vois
pas une une accélération ou une
massification de de budget sur la
recherche pour relancer l'industrie je
vois plutôt effectivement une on va dire
quelques éléments facilitateur en
utilisant notamment des labels
territoire d'industrie d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que vous en
pensez merci Bernard buit merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Président ma
question portait sur la promotion des
filières de l'industrie auprès des
jeunes mais vous avez largement répondu
et je me concentrerai juste sur le
concours une assise pour l'industrie
concours que vous avez lancé à jusqu'en
juin 2024 concours qui invite les élèves
à concevoir une assise pour l'industrie
en produisant un prototype physique ou
en réalisant une maquette virtuelle ou
une produ numérique est-ce que vous avez
déjà un retour sur les inscriptions
c'est encore trop tôt merci à vous
monsieur le
Président alors sur pardon pour répondre
à Monsieur J
sur sur tout ce qui est norme et
position
pardon je pensais l'avoir allumé je l'ai
coupé excusez-moi non non pour répondre
clairement sur les sujet
européen la question du produit fini
c'est d'abord une question de
faisabilité et notre
opposition sur ce sujet elle vient du
fait que définir à l'entrée de l'Europe
le contenu carbone d'un produit fini est
un exercice c'est une question que j'ai
posé à tous les gens compétents dans le
domaine que j'ai rencontré j'attends
toujours une réponse satisfaisante qui
ne soit pas détourné à
l'origine par le pays producteur en
faisant une allocation fictive de de de
de son énergie et finalement ce qu'on
voit
on en parlera après mais je vous dis je
j'ai posé beaucoup de questions et je
n'ai pas
vu un exercice qui soit vraiment
satisfaisant et notamment qui soit
robuste aux pratiques commerciales ou au
mesures de contournement qui pourrait
être décidé ou élaboré dans le pays qui
nous envoie le qui nous envoie le le
produit sur le B europen Act je vous
confirme qu'il n'y a aujourd'hui pas de
consensus en Europe entre les
organisations patronnales sur ce sujet
en revanche la position de France
industrie est très claire nous la
soutenons et on se heurte à une
difficulté aujourd'hui telle que je la
mesure alors peut-être que ma
formulation est malheureuse et je m'en
excuse par avance mais les Américains
sont d'accord pour faire un bail
américanac parce qu'ils sont une nation
l'Amérique ce qu'on observe dans les
discussions c'est qu'un polonais sera
sans doute d'accord pour faire un by
polish Act un espagnol un by Spanish Act
un Allemand un by German Act
mais que quand on monte au niveau de
l'Europe je sais pas si c'est vrai dans
tous les pays mais en tout cas on se
rapproche de quelque chose qui est
accessible quand on monte au niveau de
27 pays on voit bien qu'il n'y a de
consensus nulle part pour se dire qu'il
faudrait monter à l'étage de l'Europe et
c'est bien à l'étage de l'Europe que ce
sera efficace d'autant plus qu'à l'étage
d'un pays c'est globalement interdit par
les règles européennes donc et donc on
contourne avec du contenu local avec des
règles et on l'a vu avec les voitures
électriques ça donne des solutions qui
sont h complexe pour essayer d'atteindre
l'objectif qui est que des subventions
mais les Chinois et les Américains n'ont
aucun étadame pour dire pas un sous
d'argent public pour des produits qui
sont pas fabriqués en Chine ou aux
États-Unis donc je sais pas à quel
moment on sera capable de le faire mais
je pense que ça fait partie des
objectifs stratégiques qu'on devrait
avoir et je suis obligé de reconnaître
que la maturité des différentes
organisations et des différents états
sur ce sujet m'amène a pensé
que on y a
malheureusement et puis pardon et pour
finir de répondre moi je suis un grand
adepte du libre échange mais il faut que
les règles soient équivalentes et tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'au
moment de la crise des années 30 le fait
que les pays soient refermés chacun sur
eux a aggravé la crise donc on voit bien
les conséquences des restriction au
libre échange mais dans un monde dans
lequel tous les autres se referment et
mettent des des barrières et ben il vaut
mieux que le dernier qui reste le fasse
aussi parce que s'il est le seul à être
ouvert là il souffre encore plus que sil
s'est protégé et donc c'est tout cet
équilibre mais c'est comme sur la
réglementation et tous les les sujets
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
comment est-ce qu'on est capable avec le
monde économique de de construire les
points d'équilibre dans lequel on avance
dans la bonne direction et je veux le
redire sur les sujets de décarbonation
et d'environnement le monde industriel
que je représente est pleinement engagé
avec cette limite que si vous nous en
demandez trop à un moment donné on ne
répondra pas par du mieux mais par du
moins et c'est ce point d'équilibre
qu'il faut qu'on recherche en permanence
et en tout cas France industrie se veut
avec la représentation nationale et tous
les services de l'État un partenaire
responsable de dialogue pour essayer de
construire ce point d'équilibre alors on
y arrive plus ou moins bien mais en tout
cas c'est notre
volonté euh pardon sur tout ce qui est
recherche
pour répondre à Monsieur cnon je pense
que on a le C on a France 2030 qui a été
construit à partir de priorités qui ont
été élaboré par le monde économique
c'est le rapport potier c'est les 14
filières d'avenir dans ce domaine je
pense là aussi on est dans un bon
exemple de dialogue d'identification
partagée des endroits où on peut avancer
et ensuite dans ce catalogue ou dans
cette liste de prioris l'état l'état on
a choisi cont tenu de ses moyens et de
ses arbitrages un certain nombre mais on
est bien en
face de sujets où on pense qu'on est
capable d'avancer et nous on est
convaincu qu'on construira l'industrie
de demain et la rindustrie de la France
sur de l'innovation sur de la
technologie sur de la montée en gamme
mais tout ça ça coûte donc il faut être
capable d'investir cétait évoqué par
madame la Présidente on n'est pas encore
au bout des effets de la remontée des
taux
d'intérêt sur la capacité
d'investissement de nos entreprises dans
un conjoncture économique qui est un peu
moins porteuse qu'il y a un an donc
c'est tous ces équ qu'on essaie en
permanence de mesurer et j'en profite
puisque vous me tendez une perche même
ind direct sur l'innovation pour vous
dire que le CIR est un magnifique outil
qui profite très largement à l'industrie
et que notre demande est très simple ne
toucheer à rien je ne leuri pas dit à
cette occasion je pense que c'est mes
mendants qui m' qui me
l'urit
pardon non non non voilà et avec ça j'ai
oublié la dernière
question sur le concours ah oui bah on
est au enfin encore une fois c'est t
juin 2024 c'est c'est juin 2024 on a
essayé de faire vivre ce sujet il est un
peu tôt pour vous donner une approche un
peu quantitative et tangible mais en
tout cas là aussi je mercie pour la
question parce que non mais c'est c'est
une bonne illustration je ne sais pas ce
qui va effectivement marcher mais on
s'est vraiment pris en main autour de ce
sujet de l'attractivité de faire rêver
autour de l'industrie de donner à voir
ce qui est l'industrie d'aujourd'hui
encore ce qu'elle sera de demain et ce
concours est une modeste contribution à
essayer de faire vivre auprès des jeunes
et de et de tout notre écosystème qui
s'intéresse à l'industrie c'est ce que
je moi je vois tous les jours une
industrie formidable qui avance et qui
décarbone merci alors on va y arriver il
nous reste quatre questions
Anne-Catherine Loisier Jean-Marc Boyer
Sophie prima Fabien Guay et on devrait
presque terminer à l'URE merci
rapidement madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président au cœur des enjeux de la
réindustrialisation il y a l'accès aux
ressources et métau stratégique je sais
pas si vous en avez parlé j'ai j'ai pas
j'étais pas là en début de de votre
intervention malheureusement ces
ressources elles sont inégalement
réparti sur la planète et l'Europe et la
France en particulier en produisent en
quantité marginale non seulement n'en
produisent pas mais en plus elles en
transforme peu puisqu'on sait que 4 à 90
% sont transformés en Chine donc c'est
dire la dépendance et la fragilité de
nos industries en matière
d'approvisionnement de ressources
essentielles donc je voulais savoir ce
que que vous pensiez et comment évolue
le le fond métau qui a été créé je crois
en mai
dernier comment évolue aussi le critical
war materials Act adopté au au niveau
européen là aussi je crois au printemps
dernier est-ce que à votre avis ils sont
calibrés pour répondre à ces enjeux
alors je répare mon oubli parce qu'il
était très très en haut de la pile
Franck monoger et après Jean-Marc merci
madame la Présidente il y a pas il y a
pas de souci merci monsieur Sobo pour
pour cet échange j'aurais deux petites
questions êtes-vous favorable à la à la
conclusion de de de PPA la réforme du
marché européen de l'électricité qui se
dessine le le permettrait donc de
contrat entre producteur et industriel
c'est-à-dire de de de
entre producteur d'électricité
industrielle c'est-à-dire de de contrat
d'intéressement des gros consommateurs
aux investissements à financer pour être
au rendez-vous donc de de
l'électrification des carboner des des
usages voilà c'est c'est un système qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui
euh qui qui peut avoir un certain avenir
ça ça m'intéresserait de de de de de
savoir ça ça permettrait entre autres de
répondre à un de vos soucis permanents
que je que je partage évidemment qui est
celui de la de la prévisibilité de la
stabilité et et de l'optimisation des
des des prix de l'électricité du point
de vue des des industriels consommateurs
et ma deuxième petite question quelle
place voyez-vous à terme alors on n'est
pas dans une situation où la technologie
aujourd'hui est mature pour les SMR dans
l'industrie parce que je pense que là
aussi il a a il y a un sujet qui qui
peut bouleverser un petit peu l'économie
de l'électricité pour les consommateurs
industriels et les gros consommateurs
industriels en particulier d'électricité
merci Jean-Marc Boyet oui merci
euh dans dans mon département une
industrie pneumatique Michelin travaille
beaucoup sur la
décarbonation dans le domaine de
l'industrie comme dans le domaine
agricole vous nous parlez du niveau
d'exigence imposé en France avec des
transposition française qui pénalise nos
entreprises alors que les importations
n'ont pas le même niveau d'exigence
alors qui décide en fin de compte de ces
transpositions françaises dans le
domaine de l'industrie comme dans
d'autres domaines et deuxième question à
vouloir être plus vertueux que nos
voisins ne pensez-vous pas que ces
règles imposées par le ver
conduisent notre économie française sur
la pente de la décroissance je crois que
le président a déjà largement répondu
Jean-Marc oui Sophie
prima merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur le le président moi
j'ai quelques questions très très
rapides vous avez parlé du défi de la
compétitivité et notamment en indiquant
que les entreprises françaises étaient
plus taxé que les autres est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire un point là-dessus
quelles sont les taxes que vous voudriez
encore baisser nous on a un souci ici à
la Chambre des territoires qui est la
disparition de la CVAE vous avez dit
textuellement on ne fera rien sur le
sans le territoire d'accueil aujourd'hui
le territoire d'accueil va être compensé
au lieu d'avoir une recette qui est une
recette dynamique qu'est-ce que vous
avez derrière cette baisse de la
compétitivité deuxième élément j'aurais
aimé que vous nous fassiez un petit
point rapide sur les écoles de
production on a compris que vous y étiez
favorable mais aujourd'hui quel est
l'engagement de l'industrie dans ces éc
de production et troisièmement nous
avons beaucoup bataillé ici pour mettre
le logement dans la loi d'industrie
verte parce qu'on considérait que les
grandes entrepris très grande qui
s'implante elles viennent avec beaucoup
de nécessités de de personnel et qu'il
faut les loger on n pas réussi quel est
votre point de vue là-dessus alors
Fabien Guay et Daniel Salm m'excusant
avec Daniel je l'ai aussi
loupé merci Madame la président monsieur
le Président il a beaucoup de choses à
dire mais pareil je vais m'en tenir au
fond moi je suis un peu frustré parce
que je trouve que vous arrêtez au milieu
du gay c'est-à-dire que vous nous donnez
des solutions mais pas toutes et moi je
pense qu'il faut il faut il lorsqu'on
est dans un débat comme ça il faut y
aller assez Franco par exemple je en
trois questions je reprends la question
de Madame prima dites-nous quelle taxe
il faudrait abolir mais en même temps il
faut nous dire si on abolit un certain
nombre de taxes est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord qu'on arrête les 162 milliards
de cadeaux fiscaux chaque année aux
entreprises don le C parce qu'on peut
pas dire d'un côté euh on a trop taxé
mais en même temps on ne rappelle pas
assez les entreprises françaises sont
les plus aidées au monde deuxièmement
par exemple vous dites que vous êtes
pour le marché tout ça et vous en avez
tout à fait le droit mais par exemple on
a la question du du sur l'électricité
effectivement on a une énergie la plus
des carboné la plus efficace sauf que ça
c'est pas le marché qui l'a réglé c'est
un service public avec un monopole
public et donc quand on a des entreprise
qui croit au marché mais lorsque ça
dérègle comme on a connu les deux
dernières années on appelle l'État et on
dit au secours il faut maintenant
revenir à quelque chose d'équilibre donc
moi je trouve qu'il y a une question qui
est posée avec la crise énergétique soit
on reste dans le prix du marché et dans
le marché européen de l'énergie et donc
on accepte à un moment donné que le prix
s'envole qu'on ne le mise pas et qu' a
des entreprises qui ferment ou alors on
se dit il y a une autre solution c'est
revenir à un service public un monopole
public parce queon peut maîtriser les
coûts de production avec les prix c'est
une question non je la pose et trè m
chose c'est sur justement les normes et
tout ça vous en avez beaucoup parlé moi
je pense qu'il faut dire et c'est là où
je moi je je je trouve que vous arrêz un
peu au milieu du gay parce qu'on a
souvent ça le modèle social les normes
environnementales et sociales mais il
faut nous dire concrètement quoi par
exemple vous avez dit une un des
attraits pour
réindustrialiser c'est après avoir des
services publics des écoles et cetera
mais ça c'est un modèle social qui se
finance donc s'il y a pas ce modèle
social il y aura pas aussi tous ces
attraits deuxème question et j'en finis
par là sur la question des salaires
parce que c'est une des questions de la
des industrialisation moi je vous le dis
je ne rêve pas d'un modèle où on paye
les salariés 2 ou 300 € mais c'est un
débat donc est-ce que par exemple sur
cette question des salaires non mais je
dis pas que vous avez dit ça et personne
n'a dit ça mais lorsqu'on dit il y a
trop de normes sociales et
environnemental il faut nous dire quoi
par exemple comme un des points
d'accroche c'est les salaires est-ce que
vous êtes pour qu'on baisse les salaires
ou est-ce que par exemple dans le moment
que nous vivons nous sommes pour
augmenter les salaires voyez je pense
que ça c'est du quand on rentre dans le
dur ça c'est des débats intéressants et
on peut en sortir des choses et après
peut-être qu'on sera pas d'accord infé
merci Fabien pour autant quand même on a
eu d'ors et déjà un débat intéressant
Daniel salmon très rapidement merci très
très rapidement pour rebondir vous avez
vos mots on peut-être dépasser votre
pensée vous avez parlé d'une industrie
sans état d'âme vous avez dit également
qu'il n'y avait pas de bonne industrie
pour vous je pense que l'industrie n'est
pas hors de notre biosphère et qu'elle
doit s'intégrer avec les enjeux à venir
juste pour revenir mon mon collègue à
côté en a parlé des énergies
renouvelables
aujourd'hui le photovoltaïque se
développe d'une manière exponentielle
dans le monde 415 GW installés l'année
dernière 1000 Gow en 2030 l'Inde et les
les États-Unis ont fermé leur marché au
panneau bradé de Chine qu'est-ce que
l'on fait comment est-ce qu'on réagit
vous avez parlé d'ouvrir de fermer
quelle est votre vision sur cette
affaire si vous le permettez puisque
nous allons discuter en hémicycle la
semaine prochaine le projet de réforme
de la fusion ASN IRSN je voudrais que
vous connaître votre votre avis en tout
cas celui de l'industrie sur ce projet
de réforme merci
beaucoup et tout ça en 4 minutes si j'ai
bien regardé l'heure
alors je voudrais pas faire attendre AR
Rousseau euh très rapidement sur tout ce
qui est méth stratégique je j'irai un
cramp plus loin c'est tous les enjeux de
souveraineté je le redis hein nous notre
conviction je partage à la définition de
l'ugala la souveraineté c'est pas tout
faire tout seul c'est faire suffisamment
de choses suffisamment bien pour qu'on
soit aussi dépendant des autres qui sont
dépendants de nous et donc la question
c'est sur tous ces sujets méth
strratégiqu qui sont très peu en Europe
alors au-delà des quelques endroits on
veut même pas regarder ce qu'on a mais
c'est très marginal euh le vrai sujet
c'est de faire une cartographie c'est
tout ce qui est fait avec le fond pour
être capable d'investir et être sûr que
là où on a des enjeux on traite avec des
gens sur qui on est où on en a
suffisamment de fournisseurs où on est
suffisamment fort pour se dire ils vont
jamais nous couper les vives parce que
les conséquences d'une décision de ce
type seraiit pour eux aussi dévastateur
que pour nous et vous avez tout à fait
raison d'insister non seulement sur la
matière première mais sur là où est
transformé parce que notamment sur les
TER rares un certain nombre de choses le
lithium et cetera les industries de
transformation de ces de ces matières
premières sont assez loin des standards
notamment quand elles sont exploitées en
Chine auquels on aspire et je sais pas
si on a toutes les solutions là
technologiques pour le faire dans une
bonne condition chez nous et je pense
que si je promouvais massivement l'idée
qu'on fait ça chez nous monsieur jade me
tirait très vite les oreilles mais il
faut non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on n pas toujours sûr de pouvoir le
faire dans des conditions cont tenu ce
qu'on l' encore jamais fait et que je ne
maîtrise pas tous les solutions
techniques pour y
arriver mais tout ce qu'on sait faire
chez nous moi je suis très pour aussi
sur les pipi donc ça existe déjà sur les
l'énergies renouvelable l'idée c'est
avec les contrat d'allocation de
production nucléaire de pouvoir faire
sur le nucléaire existant et la question
c'est pas tant l'outil que les
conditions c'està-dire que derrière un
contrat de ce type c'est quelle avance
en tête quel niveau de prix dans la
durée quel type d'engagement comment on
exerce la clause de Take or pay et
cetera et donc quelles sont les
entreprises qui sont capables de les
signer mais l'outil aujourd'huique il
existe est-ce qu'on peut l'étendre à
l'hydraulique comme le font aujourd'hui
les Norvégiens il y a un certain nombre
de questions posées mais l'outil existe
la question c'est comment on le met en
œuvre et est-ce que ça répond à la
problématique de compétitivité place des
SMR benah je suis comme vous je
j'aimerais bien que ça marche je pense
que si on y arrive dans des conditions
de sécurité c'est un un levier je pense
notamment nos territoires ultramarins où
on peut être capable de poser des
solutions finalement de taille
raisonnable aujourd'hui le vrai sujet
c'est la la barrière technologique
c'est-à-dire quand on écoute les gens
qui le font ça peut faire rêver après on
sait tous que la somme des contraintes
qui est RD tout ça sont
assez sont assez élevés alors ensuite
c'est décarbonation monsieur Boyer
est-ce que je su- pardon j'arrive pas à
relire la
question estce que don
ah oui qui décide pardon c'est tout ce
qui est surtrposition bah pardon mais
c'est vous ENF je veux dire la
transposition d'une règle européenne
c'est
le c'est le Parlement
pour pour beaucoup de sujets et c'est
quand c'est directement règlementaire
c'est c'est
l'état et là nous on on défend une on
défend une règle assez simple c'est que
on se pose la question avant d'aller ou
au maximum des seuils ou au-delà même
des fourchettes qui sont proposés par
l'Europe qu'on se pose la question de la
faisabilité technique ou technologique
je pense à des sujets sur les poussières
de bois on avait réussi à fixer un seuil
qui était au-delà de tout ce que les
machines existant dans le monde savaient
faire pour filtrer l'air donc de toute
façon l'activité c'était on arrête où on
respecte pas la règle donc on a fait on
a réussi à faire bouger des choses mais
mais nous on ne peut qu'alerter à chaque
fois que le seuil qu'on nous fixe va
avoir des conséquences ou en terme de
faisabilité technique ou en terme de
pertere de
compétitivité et ensuite malheureusement
la décision
elle relève de de des différents
instruments législatifs ou
réglementaires qui sont
prévus qui sont prévus à cet effet sur
les impôts de production sur ce qu'on
peut encore
supprimer je d'abord nous on milite pour
qu'on on réduise tout ce qui pèse de
façon àormalement élevé sur l'industrie
je rappelle que l'industrie c'est tout
compris un peu plus de 12 % de son poids
dans pi l'industrie paye 25 % de la
CVAE donc c'est un impôt que je
qualifierais dans son effet
d'antiindustriel puisqueon paye beaucoup
plus que son poid dans le PIP c'est
pareil pour la C3S même si elle a été
reconcentrée on paye de nouveau plus de
20 % de de la C3S et d'ailleurs sur la
C3S il y a pas d'effet collectivité
après je veux le redire et pas seulement
parce que je suis dans cette grande
maison qui représentent nos nos
territoires je crois profondément qu'il
faut trouver les solutions pour garder
un lien entre activité économique et
territoire y compris sur le plan
fiscal je pense que il y a des solutions
qui sont accessibles autour d'impôts
nationaux à à à dynamique c'està-dire
don la ressource quand vous regardez
l'évolution de la CVAE et de la TVA on
est sur des choses qui sont assez
proches et les et les dynamiques
d'assiette sont si vous le regardez sur
la durée assez proches la question c'est
comment on recrée un lien entre
l'activité et la code par que reçoit le
territoire il me
qu'on pourrait travailler utilement sur
des questions d'assiette c'est qu'une
fois qu'on a défini une part qui est
reversée au territoire la répartition de
cette part va dépendre du développement
que ce soit de l'emploi de
l'investissement d'un territoire et un
territoire qui accueille plus d'activité
verra dans la règle de répartition se
verra confier un avantage parce que Ben
celui qui a accueilli un milliard
d'investissement qui a une masse salari
qui augmente parce qu'il a un
établissement qui a créé 1000 emplois il
va avoir en terme de règle de partition
un avantage al après est-ce que ça
fonctionne quelles sont les conséquences
je peux pas évidemment tout faire tout
seul et on est prêt à travailler avec
tout ce qu'il souhaite mais en tout cas
nous on défend l'idée qu'il faut qu'il
reste un lien entre l'activité
économique et le territoire qui
l'accueille tax foncière il reste la
taxe foncière il reste un certain nombre
d'éléments de de la CFE euh voilà après
il y a aussi d'autres il y a aussi
d'autres lignes de charge mais là on va
renvoyer sur d'autres questions qui sont
l'équilibre des finances publiques la
maîtrise des dépenses et puis quelques
questions qui m'ont été posées sur les
services publics et l'accueil mais
encore une fois avec l'arrivée de
nouvelles activités avec l'arrivée de
salariés il y a aussi de la création de
richesse qui va avec et des ressources
fiscales qui vont arriver naturellement
autour de tout ça puisqu'on a quand même
un taux de prélèvement qui est qui est
tout à
fait qui est tout à fait fort alors je
veux je je veux le redire sur les
salaires je pense avoir dit dans la dans
la projection que j'ai donné sur
l'industrie on pense que l'industrie de
demain c'est une industrie qui est
innovante qui est tournée vers l'avenir
qui monte en gamme donc le sujet c'est
évidemment pas pour les chiffres qui ont
été évoqués de payer des
collaborateurs au niveau qui ont été
évoqué hein c'est par la montée en
compétence c'est par l'intelligence
individuelle et collective qu'on
arrivera à répondre au défis de demain
et pas par la lutte effrainée sur le
coût et en particulier sur le coût
salarial par rapport
par rapport à d'autres pays enfin sur
sur la question des normes je pense y
avoir largement répondu c'est une
question de de réglementation c'est une
question d'équilibre et d'être capable
en permanence de se de se poser cette
question sur le sans État d'â j'ai
l'impression qu'on a un tout petit peu
coupé ma phrase pour être honnête mais
en tout cas sur tous ces sujets je je
quand je dis je suis sans État d'â
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas à moi de
choisir les bons les moins bons et je
pense que compte tenu de l'ensemble des
règles qui s'imposent à la la France
toute activité industrielle qui vient
s'implanter chez nous se sera
contributive à la protection de
l'environnement par rapport à la laisser
dans un pays qui est moins exigeant et
d'importer les produits qui seront faits
là-bas pour
expliciter la formule enfin sur la
question que madame la Présidente a bien
voulu me poser nous on est là c'est
l'industriel qui parle on est
effectivement très attaché à ce que le
projet de rapprochement entre l'IRSN et
et l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire puisse
se faire pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on a un formidable projet industriel
de construction de d'un certain nombre
de de central nucléaire qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à 14 qu'on est le seul pays
du monde dans lequel on a cette diarchie
et que dans l'exécution d'un projet de
ce type il nous
semble que ça à la fois ne présente pas
de risque et améliorera la transparence
la simplicité l'efficacité du dispositif
et j'en profite quand même pour rappeler
sur notre parc nucléaire là aussi quand
on est on essaie de se comparer à
d'autres pays du monde que l'ensemble
des règles qu'on s'impose je ne pense
pas que les autres grands pays
industriels qui ont des centrales je
pense notamment à nos américains soi
moins soucieux que nous de la sécurité
l'ensemble des règles qu'on s'impose se
traduit par des coûts de maintenance et
des périodes d'indisponibilité de nos
centrales qui sont bien supérieurs à ce
qu'on rencontre dans d'autres pays du
monde donc jusqu'à quel point encore une
fois je dis pas qu'il faut réduire les
exigences mais se poser les questions du
pourquoi et essayer d'apporter les
réponses à la fois les plus efficaces et
les plus pragmatiques et en tout cas
dans ce domaine on défend l'idée que
d'avoir un seul interlocuteur qui a à la
fois l'autorité et la compétence
technique et qui met tout ça en œuvre
pour accompagner un formidable chantier
industriel qui va s'étaller sur
plusieurs dizaines d'années et sans
doute une solution pragmatique et
efficace merci beaucoup monsieur le le
président de nous avoir consacré autant
de temps et avec des
réponses extrêmement précises et vous
avez je crois pratiquement
répondu à l'ensemble de nos collègues
c'était un exercice long pour vous mais
vraiment très intéressant et on ne
manquera pas de vous réinviter en tout
cas merci et vos propos ne sont pas
restés au milieu du gay en tout cas
c'est pour moi véritablement ce que j'ai
pu constater à travers votre interention
merci aussi Monsieur le Directeur et
bonne journée à
vous merci pour votre temps votre écoute
et comme toujours à la disposition de la
représentation nationale pour faire
avancer la cause de l'industrie et
poursivre nos débats peut-être avec un
peu plus de
si vous le souhaitez ou si l'invité
suivant est un peu plus tard ou pas de
souci